now you got your vaccine yeah i got the
j j i got that j
and j that one shot i love that
everybody talks about which one they got
yeah did you ever think would be talking
about this because i'll be someplace and
someone will say yeah i got madara and
i'll say like
i got madarana yeah no and then suddenly
it's like you're an aries i'm an aries
exactly who cares which one you got
yeah no no but let's if you get the jnj
you're really keeping it real
all you people need two shots we're the
ones who are really keeping it real
i got one shot and i went home did you
have any side effects from it oh yes i
had all the side effects yeah i had all
this
i definitely got real medicine some
people were saying it was fake no i got
real medicine
yeah yeah well i you know it this is so
important because
i've been uh open about the fact that
i'm now
two weeks out officially from my second
shot i got moderna
and yeah i got some side effects you
know i got some side effects from it but
my point was yeah you're supposed to
yeah
and they're not that bad and you get
through them and that's like a message
you want to get out there which is
actually probably a sign that the
vaccine is doing what it's supposed to
do
it is and i think you know right now if
you read the news there's lots of like
other variants happening and so we all
need to get vaccinated
or else we're just leaving ourselves
open to another you know a version of
covid
that will come across the way so we have
to we're going to get vaccinated now
it's
especially important there is a
well-earned suspicion of vaccines
in the black community well there's a
well-earned suspicion of a couple areas
as well earned suspicion of
the united states government there's a
well-earned suspicion of
the medical industry there's a
well-earned suspicion of
let's just say everything let's just say
of america can we
put all under america right so i
understand that like
that uh and you know black people that
we are a little bit skeptical which is
why it was important for me i did a
thing with a bunch of black doctors and
healthcare workers for black doctors and
healthcare workers talking to black
people about the vaccine
in ways that black people understand if
i played it for you you wouldn't
understand it but uh
yeah i didn't know and just the whole
thing you just said nothing to me
yeah and i just heard a lot of like a
high just a high pitched squishy
[Music]
now that i understand that i understand
yes yes but uh but i do think and
it's it's other communities as well i i
know people
i work with people whose um
parents immigrated to this country from
other places who are suspicious of the
vaccine
uh and they they just it's culturally
i mean we're up against a lot of
cultural stuff as well and we're also up
against a lot i don't know if you
remember the last four years of america
we're up against a lot of misinformation
and lies so
you know i mean if you look at the
research you know if you want to get a
vaccine you can't get one in your
community
go to trump country because they don't
trust the vaccine either
so i think that we have to understand
that like there's a lot we have we are
awash in misinformation and lies right
now so a lot
of people don't trust the vaccine
because they're taking in the wrong
information
well what's fascinating to me is anybody
who's had a brush with the disease
actually had covid or known someone had
covet they they get religion really
quickly
yeah yeah which is which we shouldn't
have to do that no it's too bad yeah uh
you know there's
it's in the news that yankees the mets
are offering free tickets to anybody who
gets
uh a coveted vaccine and this a little
bit goes back to
we were talking about with the family
feud is you know if we want to solve
america's problems maybe we should offer
people
you know uh a new car but um
incentives feel like they might be a
good idea in this situation it's weird
to say
want to save your life we'll give you
something for free yeah but that feels
like where we are right now
well yeah and i think well there's a lot
of us who are like i would just like to
save my life tell me what to do you know
i will wear a seat belt but for other
people you have to incentivize
especially with kobe because it's not
just about your life it's about the
lives of the people around you in the
community in the country and the world
so you have to incentivize it i think
they should just like wasn't it krispy
kreme giving out donuts
yeah i think they should just sneak up
behind people jab a vaccine into them
and they go hey
donut
because you'd immediately forget that's
right how how dare you
just like yes donut donut that's i think
we should just look at it that way like
we have to because we have to get
vaccinated or else we're
how do i put this we're doomed yeah well
what a lovely
yeah you know what a lovely sentiment
this is this is why i'm the comedian who
works at cnn
i gotta say i saw you live many times
you would always end on we're doomed
yeah that was
it always bummed the crowd out i was
trying to make it a catchphrase
but that didn't seem to work we're
doomed he's about to be off he's gonna
do we're doomed right now
here we go that's my closer